اعتذر عليه ودخرون باتهام واضح تقوم
طالبان بمنع قاطع لجميع نشرات كل من اذاعه
صوت امريكا واذاعه الحريه وكان الطالبان
قد منعت برامج صوت امريكا التلفزيوني
المعروف باسم اشناتيبي مارس الماضي والتي
كانت تعرض على قنوات محليه لعده ساعات
الاذاعتين نتيجه الفسخ العقد بينهما وبين
وزاره الثقافه وتم فسخ العقد لانهما لم
يراعيان مبادئ الصحفيه والاصول الاعلاميه
من جانبه فقد ظهر حسيب الكوزي مدير صوت
امريكا للجناح الافغاني في مقابله مع
التلفزيون صوت امريكا باللغه البشتو
مطمئنا مستمعي اذاعه صوت امريكا بان نشرات
الاذاعه ستصلهم حيث ما كانوا نعم
نشرتنا سوف لا تكون عبر موجات اف ام
افغانستان ولكن عندنا نشرات على الموجات
القصيره والمتوسطه وستكون هذه النشرات
مستمره على هذه الموجات دون خلل او تعطيل
نصيب الله صاحب التكسي في مدينه كابول
العاصمه يقول انه منذ طفولته يستمع الى
اذاعه مختلفه بما فيها اذاعه صوت امريكا
ولكنه هو منذ يومين لم يعد يستمع الى هذه
الاذاعه
حاليا
فقط لانه تم اغلاق الاذاعات الخارجيه مثل
اذاعه صوت امريكا والاذاعه الحره وغيرها
من الوسائل الاعلاميه والاذاعات الخارجيه
يذكر ان طالبان حظرت في بدايه العام
الجاري بس البرامج الاعلاميه الدوليه بما
في ذلك الدوش الى عبر التلفزيونات المحليه
طالبا تبرر مالها بان تقاريرها هاتين
الاذاعتين كانت احاديه دون مراعاه المبادئ
الاعلاميه وانها اتخذت القراره بناء على
الشكاوى التي تلقتها بشان محتوى برامج
هاتين الاذاعتين عبد الاله نادر العربيه
كابول